[Music]
you cannot expound to get out Republican
yeah
if you were lyin anymore
dentist will shoot you that's not what
you said before I seen it on you soon
life begins at conception
you sure do flip-flop a lot check out
his bumper sticker I took this in the
parking lot beyond building a wall I
prayed in the steeple my daddy was poor
I've heard lots of sad people paid off
my student debts I swear I ain't faking
my Jesus tattoos got a tattoo a radiant
lad put into danger it ain't just his
man and he needs to push him back a
little like they did with Sean Hannity
he's being aggressive just like I've
been telling it put in a pin this
dangerous is Bill Cosby was selling it
in our servers the solution a top we
just fill all of our servers with some
pictures of us you think he's tough on
China well that's a weak Betty I'll be
so tough on China you think you're at a
Greek Wedding was a deficit I'm the dead
is the same with spending money like an
Arab a dime on the exchange here just
look at this graph because it ain't
getting better yo e these are the
ratings for the new Caitlyn Jenner show
see I'm a Christian man you know how it
is when God opens a window he closes a
bread and what do I do for fun golf
despite my back hurt and go to Bernie
Sanders rallies try to find a black
purse like I'm Jared from Subway some
tops up Oh y'all don't feel renewed
[Music]